So I'm here with Courtney Drake,
who's a product manager here at Udacity.
So thank you for talking to us today.
>> Absolutely.
>> So the first thing I wanted to ask
was that, there's this perception for
online education that's very
disconnected and impersonal.
And does that necessarily
have to be the case?
>> I don't think it does.
And I would say that's something
that we have really focused on.
Udacity is the kind of research and
our experience with students,
that social learning is more
effective than not social learning.
And so that's something that we have
really actually invested in quite a bit,
especially this year.
I think the challenge with
social learning is that you
still want to preserve some of
the core benefits of online learning,
like self-pacing and
students' ability to kind of
have their learning schedule be
flexible around their life schedule.
So those kind of butt up against
the ability to connect students and
have them really build deep
connections with each other,
when their are not really in
a synchronous environment.
I think those are some
of the challenges.
We focus on a couple of different
ways of integrating, Interaction,
and collaboration into our
online learning platform.
The first way is through forums.
And through forums, we've really focused
on, how can we help students help each
other, and help them answer each other's
questions, and share with each other,
and share with a broader
community of students.
But it turns out that it
hasn't really been enough for
students to feel like
they are in a community.
Especially,say, when it's a nano degree
community that 500 plus students, it's
really hard to feel like I"m connected
to those other 499 other students.
So we've moved more recently
in addition to forums,
is small learning communities
that we're calling teams.
So when students sign up for
a nano degree,
this is kind of rolling
out progressively.
They get matched up with a group of
ten to 12 other students who they
then have a chat room with through the
course of their nano degree experience.
And what we're hoping will
kind of happen through that is
they build a personal connection
with those other students.
And that's kind of their first point
of contact if they have a question,
is run it by my team members.
If we can answer it ourselves awesome,
and if not then we're posting to
the forums or going to coach support
to ask for support from Udacity.
And we're hoping that will
kind of help with three
problems around social learning,
one is accountability,
is feeling like there are other people
who care about my progress, and
if I drop off that doesn't just
effect me, that effect other people.
The other is just a level of engagement.
I don't feel like I'm alone.
And the third piece is if
I'm helping other people and
I'm teaching other people,
I actually learn more that way.
So having those connections where
we can kind of have a back and
forth chat exchange,
can actually deepen what I'm learning
if I'm the one who's the helper.
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
I think that exactly what you just
described is something we try and
create in our OMS classes, which we
do it on piatza right now at least.
And I think we exactly try and create
that, is a lot of interaction among
students and very frequent interactions,
so that I feel like there is a community
here, present right now, and if I write
something I'm going to get a response.
>> Yeah.
>> Pretty quick and
pretty targeted to
what I'm talking about.
Another interesting thing that
happens in the OMS community is that
the largest social community around it
is actually a student run community.
It's run by several students who
created the Google Plus community.
And I think that creates a lot
of interesting ownership.
Because it's student run it's not this
kind of thing that I'm being handed and
being asked to play by your rules.
Is there anything we can do when
designing online technologies or
educational technology in general
to kind of allow room for
these kind of student driven
communities to emerge?
>> Yeah, so when we've
experimented with how do we help
students create small communities.
And when we have just kind of
let them have a free for all,
we found that they don't,
it's like some students start it, and
the really driven students will
start smaller communities.
And it's really awesome
when they do that, and
we've seen some great interaction.
But the norm is not,
I'm going to start a community or
I'm going to join a community on my own.
And so we've actually felt like we've
needed to give students more structure
to form those communities.
That's just why we have facilitated
this way of having them
join a team from the very beginning.
We say, tell us you're availability.
We will put you in a team.
And then let them go from there.
So we felt like we actually
needed to create that structure.
And I guess we'll see if,
how the ownership plays out there.
And even when we've
experimented with that,
saying we're going to actually
put you in teams together.
We found that, unless one student really
steps up into some kind of leadership
role, they kind of fall flat.
And so, where we've said, okay,
how do we scale really solid community
interaction if we don't necessarily
know who those students are who are
going to step up into a leadership role?
And so, they actually see it
the idea for a guides program,
is what we're calling it.
Where we're enlisting students who are
farther ahead in nano degree programs,
who have graduated, to come back and
be a guide for our teams.
So, they're coming to weekly
sessions with those teams.
And they're engaging in chat with
those teams throughout the week,
to really help them foster a sense of
community, and get to a point where
they're really gelling and can carry
themselves forward on their own.
So that's something we've just started.
It's pretty cool,
because it is actually students who
are coming back into that fray.
And it's actually really nice kind of
a motivational piece, to kind of say,
look at this other student who is in
the same place I was three months ago.
And look at all they know.
And maybe they even have a job
already that I want to get.
Eventually.
So it's a nice piece of motivation, and
it's also a way for
us to kind of have feet on the ground,
know what's going on.
And make sure that those
communities are healthy and strong.
>> That actually sounds very similar
to what we do in the EOS program,
because what you describe
is very similar to TAs.
When we solicit next semester's
TAs from this semester's students.
And I think it works really nicely
when we have a big group of very,
very good students who
are passionate about helping.
>> Yeah.
>> Who aren't just,
you know,
crossing an item of a to-do list, but
really enjoy helping out
their fellow students.
>> Yeah.
>> Perhaps, one of the most
inspiring things about
the LMS program is that
we see a lot more of those students
who want to help each other and
want to come back and work on it and
contribute to the class.
So yeah, it's been very inspiring
[INAUDIBLE] work nicely.
>> Yeah.
>> So
one thing I've noticed also is that
we have a stereotype that online
education is impersonal, disconnected.
And then, like you just said,
that there are ways we can
actually compensate for that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But are there times when
the online environment actually makes
it even better than it could
be in person, do you think?
I definitely think that there are times,
for sure.
And one piece of it is the geographical
reach that we get with online learning.
Is that we have students who
are connecting from all over the world.
And that's a really
powerful experience for
someone who has never done that before.
And if you're all in the same place,
you don't get that kind of diversity of
perspective that you do with
a global learning community.
So we definitely have that piece.
The other piece is that if it's less
synchronous and people are running on
their own schedules, it means
they're kind of available whenever.
We've actually leveraged mbile for
this with the team feature that
we just released where we have mobile
chat apps on both iOS and Android.
So I've had this happen with my own
team which I'm participating in,
where I will be at a dinner or
something.
And I see that my team chats something.
And I can just pop back in and
answer a question.
So they come ubiquitous.
Nature of the internet,
really helps students connect
more frequently with each
other than just if we're having a class
once a week or something like that.
It keeps and keeps the communication
flow happening more easily.
>> Yeah, I agree completely.
I think one of my experiences being
an instructor in this program has been
that I can sign onto Piazza that we
use for our forums right now, and
in five minutes, I can interact
with ten different students.
>> Yeah.
>> And come back an hour later
and do it again.
And in person you
really can't have that.
>> Right..
>> That frequency of interactions.
That kind of,
that perception is 27 available.
Really changes what we can do and
how often we can interact.
>> For sure.
>> Well thank you so much.
>> Absolutely.
Hope it help.